mais comme en football le coupe d'europe
seuls 90 et qualifié le comédien rock
hudson est mort dans soif 3 une nouvelle
page spéciale cinéma signé henry chapier
mesdames messieurs bonsoir le numéro un
soviétique mikhaïl gorbatchev dean en ce
moment même à l'elysée il a déjà eu un
premier entretien avec le président
mitterrand entretien de près de 2h30
tout de suite après son arrivée à paris
dans l'après midi en venant en france
monsieur gorbatchev marque l'intérêt de
l'urss pour l'europe face aux états unis
et pour un pays qui a toujours manifesté
son indépendance dans l'alliance
atlantique sur le plan franco soviétique
un volet économique important objectif
rééquilibrer les échanges commerciaux et
revoir le problème de leur financement
au soir de la première demi journée il
est naturellement trop tôt pour évaluer
les retombées concrètes d'un tel voyage
mais on peut dire d'ores et déjà que le
climat par est excellent mais menant à
fait j'ai hintermann monsieur gorbatchev
est un magicien dès ce soir
après deux heures et demie d'entretiens
avec françois mitterrand et à l'heure
des toasts qui sont prononcés en ce
moment n'est officialisé on veut dire
que tout va mieux tout porte à croire
que les relations entre la france et
l'uruguay sont à l'heure du dégel
pourtant françois mitterrand ne l'a pas
mis son drapeau dans la poche dans son
poste il a fait expressément référence
aux accords d'helsinki
c'est fondamental at il dit liberté de
conscience liberté les convictions
liberté de religion la cologne
l'afghanistan le président français ne
les a pas mentionné pas plus qu'il n'a
cité le nom de sakharov mais il a dit
ceci chaque peuple a le droit de
disposer de lui même
cela dit le principal sujet du jour a
été la paix la réduction des armements
et le projet mary quasi de guerre des
étoiles monsieur dans vachon du tour n'a
pas renoncé à son idée de convaincre le
président français de signer avec lui un
communiqué final dénonçant le projet
américain
une telle initiative française semble
peu probable en revanche le président
français a soumis cette idée à monsieur
gorbatchev
il faut at-il dit aller vers une
pratique européenne plus large
ce soir plus que jamais la formule de
dépôt semble d'actualité
lui qui parlait de belles et bonnes
ententes avec lure le président oregan
n'a pas renoncé à rencontrer le
président mitterrand avant sa propre
rencontre avec le numéro un soviétique
mikhaïl gorbatchev à genève débit
novembre le président français ayant
décliné son invitation à un sommet des
17 pays occidentaux les plus
industrialisés lui préférant un tête à
tête monsieur reggane lui propose de le
rencontrer à une date mutuellement
acceptable il aimerait connaître les
impressions at il dit de monsieur
mitterrand après ses entretiens avec
monsieur gorbatchev
alors chacun a remarqué la jeunesse de
monsieur gorbatchev et son look comme on
dit qui tranche avec celui de ses
prédécesseurs
mais qui se cache derrière cette
apparence aimable et ouverte
c'est encore un mystère en france un
seul homme le connais jean baptiste
doumeng le milliardaire rouge tête de
pont du commerce soviétique il l'a
rencontré il ya vingt ans et il a
toujours su dit il qu'il était promis à
un brillant avenir
le 10 mars 85 ans d'antenne tchernenko
meurt c'est un homme jeune qui lui
succède à la tête de l'union soviétique
il s'appelle michael gorbatchev il a 54
ans en europe et en france en
particulier on connaît mal le nouveau
numéro un soviétique
et pourtant lui connaît bien la france
en 73 il a séjourné dans cette maison à
nous et près de toulouse la maison de
jean baptiste doumeng dans le temps et
beaucoup de croûtes offre la région la
plus près pour l'appliquer des choses
qu'on correspondent à ce qu'on fait pas
licite est la sienne et le travaux paul
dont il était à l'époque jeune homme un
chausson d'auchan dechantre ce que
l'hôtel du parti de cette région
mais parallèlement à ces contacts
sérieux vous avez lier des liens
d'amitié avec l'homme oui parce que
c'est un homme dans les champs
maintenant mais chut c'est un homme
sérieux dynamique qui ne craint pas la
boutade qui aime bien vivre en
travaillant
l'histoire de la portée
je vais devoir de mémoire c'est pas lui
qui a tué tous à agressive ressasse au
poste où il était je pense qu'ils ne
souhaitaient pas du tout être le premier
les voit le temps après son séjour en
midi pyrénées il paraît que mikhaïl
gorbatchev considérer que l'agriculture
française pouvait être un exemple
positif à rabastens dans le tarn le chef
du kremlin parfaitement inconnu à
l'époque a visité des fermes et des
marchés son passage n'a pas laissé de
souvenir je penche personnellement je
pense que j'ai prévenu mes yeux parce
qu' il fallait un effort plus
particulier vers l'identité européenne
et je pense qu'il ne veut pas qu'on
croie qu'il veut se protéger le monde
les américains y les soviétiques avec la
puissance qui lui est accordé à son pays
la responsabilité qui l'emportera
l'histoire et trouver les conditions de
dialogue possible avec tous ceux qui
veulent considérer que c'est sa volonté
si et je proclame la respecte plus mi
temps messi
au cours de sa visite il ne serait pas
une grande déclaration commune c'est que
la france n'a pas su profiter de
l'occasion de se passer comme un
troisième bras ce qui sûr en tout cas
c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de place dans
le programme officiel de la visite de
michael gorbatchev en france pour une
halte à la maison de nous l'urss on le
dit souvent on vient encore de l'entente
dans le reportage de francine raymond
est un vaste marché potentiel encore
faut-il savoir à qui s'adresser journal
le monde a eu l'idée de faire un genre
de who's who soviétique les pages jaunes
de l'annuaire sur ordinateur en service
depuis mois de septembre
gilles du jonchay l'ampleur des
changements opérés par mikhaïl
gorbatchev au niveau des hommes depuis
mars dernier est telle que tout ce
cliché nous ont à faire avec l'union
soviétique peuvent avoir du mal à s'y
retrouver
en outre généralement il faut savoir
quand l'urss le responsable avec qui
l'on traite ne représentent souvent
qu'un élément dans un système beaucoup
plus large
du fait de la présence des services du
parti à tous les échelons ce sont toutes
ces raisons qui ont conduit le journal
le monde a constitué à l'intention des
administrations et des grandes
entreprises
une banque de données accessible par
minute
elle sur les institutions et les
responsables soviétiques dans tous les
secteurs
conçue et constamment mis à jour par
l'équipe de michel tu as tu cette banque
de données et à ce jour unique au monde
ce sont bien évidemment les grandes
entreprises qui commercent avec l'urss
où sont à la recherche d'investissements
possibles dans ce pays qui devraient en
être les principaux clients
nous avons tous nos programmes et les
choses de telle sorte ce sont les
institutions qui viennent d'abord alors
vous avez par exemple la première
institution de ces la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie et vous voyez
apparaître le nom français lé nom russe
le sigle son adresse son numéro de
téléphone son numéro de télé 2 semaines
ça c'est la première approche ensuite
vous pouvez alors aller plus loin et
demander les hommes qui travaillent dans
cette chambre de commerce et cetera les
hommes
on peut également sortir des
organigrammes et surtout reconstituer le
profil de prix de 5000 responsable
depuis quand un tel est à son poste avec
qui il a des affinités les loges où les
critiques qui ont pu lui être adressées
toutes choses qui peuvent être utiles
afin ne pas avoir à commettre d'impair à
l'occasion d'un échange de lettres ou
d'un déplacement dans ce pays
pour moi ce qui m'intéresse ce sont les
changements cette année dans l'industrie
du pétrole je crois qu'il ya eu pas mal
de limogeage je voudrais écrire là bas
avant des informations mais je voudrais
pas me tromper d'interlocuteur
absolument il est utile par exemple de
savoir qui est un nouveau premier vice
ministre de l'industrie de
transformation du pétrole et de la
pétrochimie qui s'appelle monsieur les
maillets fait qu'il a été donné
seulement le 14 mars
et voici justement l'ancien donc
remplacé par se lier maheshe monsieur
singh qui a été mise à la retraite en
mars 85 probablement pour des raisons
évidemment ne sont pas seulement son âge
il faut savoir qu'en effet c'est plus la
peine d'écrire monsieur 6 in situ pièce
que tu pourrais me donner la biographie
du chef du kgb d'accord tous les
soviétiques sont venus voir ils ont sont
sortis impressionné même l' agence
américaine de renseignement ils le
savent n'a pas ça
un diplomate soviétique exécuté au liban
enlevé hier à beyrouth avec trois autres
diplomates soviétiques par
l'organisation islamique de libération
le yen les ravisseurs menacent
d'exécuter les trois autres otages si
les combats contre les intégristes de
tripoli au nord du pays ne cessent pas
joël hasard c'est ce soviétique arcady
quête aux cov secrétaire consulaires à
l'ambassade de beyrouth qui a été
exécuté par ses ravisseurs
la mort de cet homme et les menaces qui
pèsent toujours sur la vie des trois
autres soviétique vienne soudainement de
bousculer les anciennes donne libanaise
jusqu'ici aucune faction n'aurait osé
s'en prendre à l'union soviétique au
liban moscou pourvoyeur en kalachnikov
mais surtout partie prenante de tous les
conflits d'ailleurs derrière la plupart
des attentats et des enlèvements et par
delà les exécutants on voyait toujours
en toile de fond la main visible tgv
alors qui a osé rompre le pacte tacite
et enlever les soviétiques
une seule certitude les ravisseurs
appartiennent à une organisation liée à
l'islam sunnite panarabe
impossible de savoir s'il existe une
complicité objective avec le djihad
islamique liés à l'iran et qui lui
revendique les enlèvements d'occidentaux
le djihad avait menacé samedi de porter
la guerre à damas et moscou si l'assaut
contre tripoli ne prenait fin mêmes
exigences que les ravisseurs des quatre
soviétique qui veulent empêcher que les
intégristes et tripoli ne soit décimée
par ces milices pro syrienne car qui
mieux que moscou peut encore arrêter le
bras armé des syriens dans ces combats
perdus d'avancé par les frères musulmans
face à cette prise d'otages sanglante
aux combats à tripoli
la réponse qu'apportera moscou sera
décisif pour l'immédiat mais aussi pour
l'avenir dans ses relations avec l'islam
nouvelles retombées de la sphère
greenpeace le nouveau ministre de la
défense paul quilès a annoncé la
suppression du centre d'entraînement des
nageurs de combat d'aspretto en corse
le centre sera regroupée avec un autre
centre d'entraînement dans
nouveaux corps le 11e bataillon
parachutiste de choc avec la fin du
centre d'aspretto c'est la renaissance
du 11e de choc allonge r on a beaucoup
on a trop parlé de la base d'aspretto
depuis le début de l'affairé greenpeace
à quatre kilomètres d'ajaccio à centre
d'entraînement ultra secret pour le
combat sous marins c'est de là que sont
partis la plupart des effectifs utilisée
pour l'opération d'abord sur louvain a
ensuite la fameuse troisième équipe
celle qui a posé les explosifs enfin
l'un des faux époux tu ranges anamah
fars avait été le numéro deux de cette
base et c'est le responsable actuel
aspretto de capitaine billets qui aurait
supervisé en personne les opérations
nouvelle zélande de dérapage en bavure
aspretto était donc sur la sellette
jugé trop autonomes elle passe sous le
contrôle de l'armée de terre d'où vient
le général 1 go la base d'aspretto la
fusionner avec le camp de cercottes près
d'orléans où se fait l'entraînement
terrestre des agents de la dgse
ces deux unités vont reconstituer le 11e
bataillon parachutiste de choc un nom
chargé d'histoire créée en 1946 intégré
au sein des camps 50 de ce bataillon
avait été mis en sommeil après nadeau
chine et l'algérie certains de ses
membres étant jugées trop favorables aux
putschistes
la version 85 sera au service de la
division actions la dgse
fini les unités autonomes
l'heure est au contrôle verticale paul
quilès a également annoncé qu'il irait
bientôt dans le pacifique pour assister
à un nouvel essai nucléaire
il a fait part de ces deux décisions à
l'assemblée nationale cet après-midi la
rentrée parlementaire s'est ouverte sur
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
il ya d'abord été question on s'en doute
de la sphère greenpeace michel diaz
en fait il ne fut même question que de
cela cet après midi dans les couloirs du
palais bourbon
d'autant que l'udf après le rpr venait
de refuser sa participation au projet de
commission d'enquêté parlementaire afin
de ne pas mettre en cause les services
de la défense
voilà pourquoi lors de la séance des
questions orales
l'ancien premier ministre michel debré
préféra dénoncé l'inefficacité du
gouvernement une affaire aussi sérieuse
qui touche au coeur des actions de
l'état une affaire aussi sérieuse qui
intéresse au premier chef les relations
internationales de la république une
affaire aussi sérieuse qui met en
mouvement des sommes élevées
comment le premier ministre que vous
êtes at il dit ignorer qu'elle allait
être entreprises dans l'opposition on
sait pas sur tous les bancs déchaînés on
ad'ailleurs d'ordinaire fait agir plus
tôt les lieutenants que les chefs les
accusations les plus sévères ont été
portés prétendument au nom de la vérité
mais pourquoi alors les mêmes
refuse-t-il de participer à la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
envisagé avait refusé d'anticiper à la
commission indépendante air pouvoir
tout simplement parce que tout a été
déjà dit et que monsieur fabius comme
monsieur un beau d'ailleurs général un
bon on dit que de toute façon tout était
verrouillé
alors dans ces cas là nous n'allons pas
aller une commission enquête pour des
faux semblants
pourtant c'est vous qui l'avez demandé
nous l'avions demandé en effet il est à
trois semaines dans un contexte
totalement différent si les communistes
continue à réclamer la commission d'
enquête parlementaire les socialistes
considèrent eux le dossier clos d'où un
consensus habituelles en matière de
défense nationale qui annulera peut-être
le projet de commission denquête les
socialistes se sont donnés à ce propos
un délai de réflexion supplémentaire
deux projets de loi adopté ce matin en
conseil des ministres celui du garde des
sceaux robert badinter créant des
chambres d'instruction trois magistrats
au lieu d'un pour les affaires pénales
et puis le projet de loi attendu sur la
création des télévisions locales privées
c'est la haute autorité qui accordera
les autorisations télédiffusion de
france conserve le monopole de la
diffusion ibérique duriez fut l'euphorie
du conseil des ministres du 31 juillet
dernier l'enthousiasmé des investisseurs
potentiels étaient retombés la décision
gouvernementale de donner à la haute
autorité le pouvoir d'attribuer des
fréquences hertziennes locales vise à
relancer la dynamique certes tdf
conserve son puissant monopole de
diffusion mais le projet d'inspiration
libérale en ce qu'il permet la création
de groupes multimédias sont reconstitués
des monopoles régionaux il prévoit en
effet qu'une personne morale pourra
contrôler trois radios et trois
télévisions hertziennes ou câblées mais
pas tous
cela étant tout le monde ne se
précipitent war et ses nouveaux espaces
de liberté sur plusieurs centaines de
demandes envoyées à la haute autorité
celles formulées par la presse régionale
se comptent sur les doigts de la main
un réalisme économique qui fait craindre
que les projets actuels émanant pour la
plupart amateurs de patin libre n'est
pas mesurer les coûts élevés du média
télévisé compte tenu du marché
publicitaire local hero 6 heures
d'émission qui sont prévus au programme
avec en télévision le gall
spécifiquement une heure une heure que
j'irai au niveau de l'information et
magazines mais il est évident que ce
qu'on souhaite réaliser ce sont des
productions locales donc le soir à 20h30
en compétition aussi je peux si je puis
dire avec les télévisions du service
public reste les deux réseaux nationaux
multivilles qui auront la priorité dans
l'attribution des fréquences disponibles
si leur viabilité économique semble
moins incertaine les négociations pour
obtenir une concession de service public
sont loin d'être bouclée rcl est pour
l'instant suspendue à un accord franco
luxembourgeois sur le satellite tdf a
quant au projet de chaîne musicale
europe1 publicis ils butent sur des
difficultés les émetteurs de tdf sont
insuffisants et le quota de production
française imposée est jugé trop lourd
rien n'est joué mais le temps est
désormais compté pour pouvoir démarrer
en janvier 86
aïe aïe aïe nantes seule équipe reste
française rescapée de la soirée de coupe
d'europe
les canaris ont battu reykjavík 3 à 0
daniel lauclair
on va voir des images je suppose de ce
match
bien sûr et en couleurs en couleurs
c'est formidable
battus à l'aller les bus vont arriver
très vite la seule équipe rescapés n'est
pas rescapés si non vous vous en
souvenez avaient été battus 2 1 en
islande face à des amateurs faut-il le
souligner et bien sûr ce soir les
nantais remis aux jaunes avaient à coeur
de laver cet affront il y sont fort bien
parvenu en inscrivant trois buts au
terme des 90 minutes 90 minutes durant
lesquelles les nantais se sont montrés
dominateurs à l'image de loïc amisse une
petite faim du pied gauche un tir très
puissant qui va dans la lucarne au
renard sonne le gardien islandais est
battu pour la première fois à 0 ce sera
d'ailleurs le score à la mi temps on va
d'ailleurs retrouver ces nantais avec
toujours loïc amisse qui donne en
retrait pour maurice le tir est contré
un ballon qui file tout droit en corner
et sur ce corner suivez bien l'action
tiré par loïc amisse c'est le deuxième
but nantais un relais avec maurice un
centre deuxième photo tête en retrait de
leurs roues et but de josé touré 2 à 0
pour le fc nantes
on ne verra pas le troisième les nantais
n'ont pas eu le temps de nous le
montrent et un troisième but marqué par
loïc amisse demi finaliste de la coupe
de champion l'an passé c'est une grosse
déception bordeaux est éliminé dès le
premier tour les bordelais avaient été
battus chez eux 3 à 2 déception
également pour monaco les deux buts
avance du match aller n'ont pas suffi
aux serres méconnaissable à milan a subi
la loi du milan ac pour metz les
miracles n'ont lieu qu'une seule fois
vous souvenez l'année dernière après
l'exploit réussi à barcelone les
lorrains n'ont pu rééditer leur
performance et enfin vous venez de le
voir c'était attendu d'ailleurs nantes
sans problème obtenu la qualification
vous le voyez si la france est
championne d'europe les que français
n'ont pas la même réussite au soir de ce
premier tour le
bilan est simplement négatif quatre
équipes sont éliminées
certes le tirage au sort n'avait pas été
favorable aux équipes françaises
mais cela n'explique pas tout toujours
est-il qu'il ne reste plus que le
football club de nantes pour représenter
le football français au niveau européen
et encore faut-il souligner que les
nantais n'ont battu que des amateurs
le comédien rock hudson est mort cet
après midi chez lui en californie il
était atteint du sida il avait 59 ans
images émouvantes
ce soir c'est lui qui avait remis son
oscar à simone signoret en 1960 à
hollywood rock hudson était alors au
sommet de sa gloire et représenter un
certain idéal de l'homme américain on
peut dire d'ailleurs qu'il a bâtie
aurait chapier sa carrière sur ce type
de personnage et que le mythe s'est
brutalement écroulées cet été lorsque
les américains ont appris avec stupeur
que rock lawson une de leur idole avait
le sida
oui mais moi je crois que cette réaction
n'est pas celle de tout le monde je
pense que la plupart des gens la plupart
de ceux qui l'ont aimée vous gaver le
souvenir de roxton danger en de stival
ils vont garder le souvenir de dynasty
est dans le coeur des femmes
il reste quand même le prototype de
l'homme de rêve ça n'a aucune importance
vous savez ça fera oublier cette affaire
du sida il ya d'autres versions
fantastique celle de liz taylor par
exemple celle de charlie mac laine ou du
dos je vais on ne monte pas en chair
nous ça n'a aucune importance c'est une
maladie comme une eau encore qu'on aura
trouvé le remède
on gardera encore et toujours le
souvenir la fabuleuse acteur alors a
beaucoup parlé de cinéma ce soir dans le
journal mais moins tristement que ce
qu'on vient de faire
christian dauriac mais moins tristement
tout d'abord parce que nous fêtons ce
soir à soir 3 premier anniversaire c'est
celui de la nouvelle formule de ce
journal dans ce décor
c'est juste un an dans lequel nous
travaillons maintenant avec un journal
plus long vous avez remarqué qui fait
quelques minutes de plus un petit peu
plus de dossiers et tout cela s'est
soldé en un an par une augmentation de
l'audience de soir 3 de près de 30%
c'est à dire que vous êtes en ce moment
en moyenne 4 millions à nous regarder
alors un an après que faire on a décidé
en fait une politique de pages spéciales
hebdomadaire la première page spéciale
c'est une page consacrée au cinéma le
mercredi et c'est henri chapier qui va
désormais nous la présenter dans
quelques minutes la deuxième page
spéciale c'est une page qui sera
programmé le dimanche et qui sera
destiné à nous montrer comment les
étrangers et les correspondants des
télévisions étrangères à paris voit
l'actualité française cette actualité
sur laquelle nous avons travaillé que
vous avez regardé tout au long de la
semaine
donc pour ce premier anniversaire
premier cadeau de première page spéciale
le cinéma henri chapier ses talents
jouera le premier film dont je vous
parlerai témoigne de notre part d'un
certain courage
il s'agit du quatrième pouvoir de serge
leroy le capitaine pouvoir vous l'avez
deviné est celui qu'on attribue à la
presse alors justement il ya une
polémique qui est née qui est courageux
la presse écrite ou la prévision alors
justement
l'interprète du film fit gloire et
s'exprime un peu à titre de citoyens et
vous allez l'entendre et l'écouter que
je crois que bon la télévision d'un âge
ne s'est jamais montré être un endroit
on pouvait faire du journalisme deux
banques est justement de ferron c'est un
journal de commentaires où c'est un
journaliste un peu suiveurs dix ans le
fait avec plus ou moins de talent mais
bon ils reprennent beaucoup d
informations et je pense pas qu'ils
aient au coude d'enquêteurs dans les
journaux télévisés alors salagnac les
journalistes et révisions sont moins
crédible que les journalistes à la
presse écrite d'après vous non je pense
pas qu'ils sont un crédit mais je pense
qu'ils ont un
ils ont moins de d'abord parce que le
temps killer qui leur est donnée pour
informer les gens et tellement réduits
en survol tellement les choses qu'on est
voilées au fond d'un sujet dans une
émission qui fait déjà 30 minutes et
dans lequel il ya six 6 ou 8 ou 10
sujets à traiter vous dire il ya
quelques années on vous a beaucoup parlé
d'un très grand cinéaste soviétique
d'origine arménienne sonne on sait
paradjanov et vous avez entendu dire
qu'il avait été emprisonné accusé
d'avoir trafiqué des oeuvres d'art
actuellement à paris à partir du 16
octobre vous aurez l'occasion de voir un
festival de films arméniens ou la
forteresse de soukhoumi fine nouveau de
paradjanov et présenter une bonne
nouvelle elle coïncide avec
arrivé de monsieur corps retrouvés à
paris paradjanov libéré depuis quelques
mois et serge avédikian qui est allé le
voir il y à peu nous parle de cette
rencontre et nous présente quelques
images regarder les réseaux nov a été
libérée il ya déjà deux ans elle il a
commencé à tourner son film il ya à peu
près un an
le film est totalement terminée on sait
qu'il a été très bien reçu au festival
de moscou
donc le film a été distribué
certainement en urss et nous avons pu
obtenir une copie pour notre festival ce
deuxième festival du film arménien on a
pu y aller parce qu'avec jacques et
badiaa on a réalisé deux films sur
l'histoire des arméniens et notamment un
film sur mon propre passé sur un retour
en arménie soviétique pour retrouver des
camarades de classe
donc on a pu faire un voyage à tbilissi
on s'est rendu chez lui et il nous a
reçus les bras ouverts et il nous a
raconté un tas de jolies histoires et
alors les albums convoi puis les dessins
tout à fait le matériel de la forteresse
par zone en fait aussi un homme qui
pendant ses années de détention a appris
à faire des collages il savait déjà mais
je veux dire s'est appliqué à faire des
collages et il fait aussi des poupées en
chiffon ou on doit d'ailleurs sa maison
les couvertes
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
constamment de ses mains vous pas fait
si on ne les fait partir pour un
festival comme celui là f qui
retourneraient là bas où il resterait là
non je crois que c'est quelqu'un qui a
envie de vivre de vivre chez lui mais je
pense qu'il faudrait sur celui permettre
de voir l'extérieur c'est un homme qui
est timmer de voyage je pense mais il
voyage dans sa tête dans ses images
le cinéma c'est aussi la femme la femme
fatale l'avant enfin tout ce qui nous
fait rêver
nous avons rencontré à ce sujet
quelqu'un d'assez rare charlotte
rampling qui tient le rôle principal
dans le film de jacques deray qui sort
dans une semaine c'est le dernier
scénario de michel audiard
ça s'appelle on ne meurt que deux fois
charlotte rampling nous parle de son
expérience avec jacques deray et michel
serrault de télé appartenait
avec jacques deray pour on ne meurt que
deux fois c'était pour moi un petit peu
là dont l'apogée c'était un des climax
de la femme vamp de la femme mystérieuse
de la femme éternelle dans les séries
noires dans l'histoire du cinéma on l'a
vu on la connaît depuis dakar oui on a
connaît de l'orne bakar de jean turn et
de lana turner de différentes actrices
qu'ils ont fait ce rôle et c'est comme
si cette personnage que je joue dans le
rôle est transposé de cette époque dans
le maintenant night before dans un rôle
justement s'il n'y a pas trop de clés
parce que les clés on les trouve en
tournant en avec le metteur en scène
avec l'acteur en face de vous vous
trouvez ses clés donc si vous avez tout
au début ça m'intéresse pas si on dit
oui bon c'est une femme qui est si ça et
ça ça ne m'intéresse pas je cherche dans
mes personnages toujours un élément deux
inconnus
pas de mystère parce qu'on sait c'est
pas ça que je cherche mais de 2,2
marginal finalement quelqu'un qu'on
qu'il faut que moi je commence à
découvrir mais ce que je veux dire
à présent c'est mon bac je vais vous
donner quelques informations mais je ne
fais pas le faire comme je viens d'y
jeter je vais donc lire je voudrais vous
dire une chose intéressante c'est pour
la première fois qu'isabelle adjani
warren beatty et dustin hoffman vont
travailler ensemble
c'est une grande nouvelle pour le cinéma
français parce qu'on dit toujours que
nous sommes repliés sur l'hexagone et
bien ce n'est pas vrai ce film
s'appellera bon c'est david rey les deux
mais le brief coeur en français j'ai
fait de traduire ce tournage aura lieu
au maroc
ces informations que je vous donne nous
sont communiquées par le film français
donc elles sont une avant première
j'aimerais aussi vous signaler parce
qu'on n'en parle jamais assez que
l'association a traversé halles qui
regroupe sept cinémas d'art et d'essai
des bouches du rhône va organiser pour
la première fois une rétrospective des
films de jean pierre mocky janvier un
mot qui signa méconnue on n'en parle pas
souvent à la télévision on a bien tort
dernière information belmondo auront la
glace qui avait entre lui et la
télévision il nous reviendra mais à
travers son prochain film qui s'appelle
hold up
vous verrez bientôt paris non des
affiches et aussi toutes les grandes
métropoles et aussi les espaces ruraux
puisqu'ils sortent dans 57 ans voilà
pour les informations et à présent
permettez moi de vous présenter un
document a fait rare c'est un tonnage
auquel j'assistais c'est de ton âge
droit david richards gear en est
l'interprète principal
et voilà à peu près ce qu'il en a dit du
roi david sujets que vous connaissez
depuis vauban 10
je n'en savais pas plus qu'un autre
trouvaille
voir c'est un homme très contemporain
attaché aux valeurs spirituelles mais
aussi aux désirs et aux aspirations de
nos modernes il serait resté un berger
sans histoire s'il n'avait été
confrontée une situation exceptionnelle
à l'époque où les prophètes était témoin
des guerres entre le peuple d'israël et
ses voisins les philistins et les autres
tribus je crois qu'il était
indispensable de retrouver le pouls de
cette époque comme si on y était et de
reconstituer au baroque le décor de la
bible c'est là bas que nous avons tourné
soit faire les berbères nous ont
beaucoup aidés dans notre jeu
un seul mot pour vous dire au revoir à
mercredi prochain mais aussi ne manquez
pas ce jour là une invitée
exceptionnelle mélina mercouri un
mercredi donc 12 centimes de moins pour
le dollar aujourd'hui à paris léger
redressement ce square à new york mais
les marchés sont très nerveux
dominique thiébaut le dollar a repris sa
glissade en s'approchant de la barre des
8 france qui le ramène un en arrière
certains cambistes craignent que de
nouvelles décisions soient prises pour
faire baisser encore le dollar en
attendant ce soir à new york
il regagnait quelques centimes une fois
encore le marché s'est montré seulement
résistants aujourd'hui à paris et il ne
s'agit toujours pas de reprise
pire les investisseurs commencent à
s'inquiéter de la nouvelle hausse du
loyer de l'argent
l'annoncé du départ de paul volcker
le président de la réserve fédérale a
fortement impressionné wall street même
si cette rumeur a été ensuite démentie
certains investisseurs considère mat